how's it done everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays I segment where you all submit
your theories I choose five to go over
each week you vote on the weekly winner
and then you vote on the overall monthly
winner and a big shout out to Nico
Gonzales for being the theory Thursday
winner for March with his Ironman
adamant IAM and vibranium Infinity
Gauntlet Theory Congrats Niko you just
won two imax tickets so you can go see
Avengers and game in IMAX okay this week
we have some great theories to go into
so let's get started theory number one
comes from angel Feliciano and it starts
an Avengers infinity war where Tony and
pepper were walking in the park and he
was telling her about the dream that he
had where they had a child named Morgan
and Angel said in regards to his dream
it wasn't it wasn't a dream it was his
memories catching up to him from a
timeline that he's already lived in
their child's name is Morgan named after
peppers eccentric uncle and Tony has
already met his child Morgan much like
what happened in Back to the Future -
and then an age of Ultron captain's
vision of him and Peggy dancing wasn't
necessarily a vision either but a mix of
an alternative timeline not where he
stays behind and doesn't go into the
ocean on the plane but rather a post
snap reversal time where he comes back
and lives his life with her this again
due to time travel
altering timelines angel goes on to say
that from everything that we know about
time travel the line timeline is
malleable is pretty prolific going
forward into Avengers endgame Angel
believes that they kill off slash deal
with feyo's sooner in the film but it
would be in his interest to look forward
in time just like Doctor Strange did and
know what's to come and warn previous
versions of himself so they in turn have
to deal with previous versions of fan
OHS as well as trying to obtain the
stones to create copies for the new
gauntlet it's certainly an interesting
theory but angel does make a point about
alternate timelines and back to the
future - is a perfect example of what
he's talking about where they create an
alternate 1985 by Biff screwing with a
timeline in 1955 giving his younger self
future info and since time-travel is
involved there's no reason why Steve
couldn't go back in time and finally get
to be with Peggy Carter but if the
Avengers do start going back to
different points in time then fan OHS
might catch
and the past versions of Thanos might
have a problem with that
Thanos does have the Infinity Gauntlet
so everything is possible and it's hard
to believe that the Avengers will go
back in time and get it right the first
time they'll probably have to go back in
time a few times before they really
figure out how to get it right and each
time they might run into a version of
Thanos so there is a chance that we
could see something like this play out
in Avengers endgame so that's it for
theory number one onto theory number two
theory number two comes from Jakob a and
he has a theory about spider-man 2099
making an appearance and Avengers in
game
The Avengers use the quantum realm to
time-travel they go forward and
backwards in time they will make at
least a few accidents when they try to
time-travel meaning they will
accidentally go to time periods they
weren't expecting to and one of those
times they arrived in 2099 when they get
there somebody asks what year are we in
and then out of nowhere a couple of
robots attacked them spider-man 2099
sees the robots attacking them and he
swings in and defeats the robots as
spider-man is fighting off the robots
the Avengers go back inside of the
quantum realm and then spider-man turns
around after defeating all the robots
doesn't see them there and is very
confused
this theory is a really fun theory and
would be a really good Easter Egg to
throw into Avengers endgame because it's
true the Avengers are going to mess up
at least once or twice when they try to
time-travel and it would be a funny
little scene to see spider-man in 2099
appear in Avengers in game as a small
little Easter egg after all we do know
that the Russo brothers loved the comics
so that's it for Theory number 2 on to
number 3 theory number 3 comes from
Cameron Valentine who has a theory about
Thor in Avengers in game Cameron says
that so far and all of the TV spot
trailers Thor isn't shown too much and
only has two lines the two of them being
I saw all those people die and I like
this one of course referring to Captain
Marvel throughout all the trailers he
seems lost in thought and traumatized by
all the deaths that he feels responsible
for for not going for the head and we
now know that some time passes in
Avengers in game maybe even a couple of
years and we know that Thor is very
emotional and highly driven by impulse
so after all this time passes Thor
probably wants to go and fight Thanos to
get a second chance but doesn't know if
it's the right decision or not so he
starts to have differences with the
Avengers and Alton
he decides that he needs to go find and
fight Thanos and then Captain Marvel has
to stop him she's the only one who's
strong enough to actually be able to
stop him this is why Thor and Captain
Marvel are missing in all of the TV
spots and trailers in the scene where
all of the Avengers are wearing their
white suits Thor and Captain Marvel have
gone off together and will most likely
form a bond after all Thor and Captain
Marvel are both extremely powerful and
emotional beings that have dealt with a
lot and the line I saw all those people
died could be Thor talking to Captain
Marvel he could be explaining everything
that has happened to him his brother
turning into evil his entire family's
death the destruction of Asgard and then
Thanos snapping away half of the people
in existence this theory does make sense
because if Thor is feeling remorse and
guilt which we know that he is and he
wants to go off and fight Thanos again
by himself Captain Marvel is the only
person who could stop him and they
aren't in the scenes and not just the
white suit scene Thor and Captain Marvel
really aren't in any scenes besides the
very beginning
besides the scene where all of them are
in the Bennet are go into space but this
would take place after that so Thor not
being able to deal with the feat wanting
to go after Thanos again and Captain
Marvel trying to stop him could happen
in Avengers in game so that's it for
theory number 3 on to number 4 theory
number 4 comes from koa cafe and koa has
a theory about time travel and Avengers
in games specifically about the Avengers
splitting off into different groups koa
says that IMAX just released two new
posters that on the Left poster had Iron
Man Bruce Banner and the Hulk Buster
armor black widow war machine nebula and
rocket and then on the right one it had
Captain America Captain Marvel Thor
Hawkeye and a qoyi KOA thinks that in
the very beginning of avengers endgame
the avengers will go into space and try
and defeat Thanos they will get defeated
and come back then when ant-man comes
back and they figure out time travel as
possible they will split into two
different groups the two different
groups will have to go back in time to
different points in time
all throughout Avengers end game and koa
says this is also backed up in a TV spot
where Captain America says you know your
teams this makes sense because I feel
like all of the Avengers going back
together at one point in time would just
be too much too many people going back
to one point makes it very complicated
because it only takes one person to
screw up a time
and the more people you have going back
gives you more chances that the time
line could get messed up and of course
Thanos will probably catch on to their
plan after all he does have the mine
stone so time is going to be of the
essence and if they're going back to
collect six different Infinity stones
they're going to have to split up it
just makes sense and Captain America
does say you know your teams in the TV
spot now the Russo brothers could be
trying to mislead us like they're known
to do but it does seem to make sense
that the Avengers would split up into
different teams while going back in time
well that's it for theory number four on
to the final theory theory number five
theory number five comes from Alex
Griffith and he has a theory about vanos
attacking the Avengers headquarters Alex
believes that when Thanos attacks the
Avengers HQ the Avengers will blow up
Tanis a ship and it will come crashing
down onto the Avengers facility this is
what causes the mass amount of
destruction we see behind Tony Stark
Captain America and nebula and the
footage where captain is strapping on
his shield Tony is using the Lightning
Redistributor and nebula is charging at
someone with her swords alex says that
some evidence to back this up would be
how we see Hawkeye Ronan running from
the outriders and a massive explosion
through a tunnel looking place the red
light in the tunnels that Hawkeye is
running through also kind of matched the
red lights on the outside of Thanos a
ship another piece of evidence is how we
see Thea knows his ship coming through a
huge cloud in space in the recent TV
spot Alex speculates that the cloud is
actually a cloud of smoke created from
the explosion of a ship we see thinnest
ship crashing towards the Avengers
headquarters that would cause all the
damage that we have seen in the new
footage this would actually make sense
because when the Avengers go to fight
Thanos in the very beginning he should
be on his farm not on the sanctuary to
his ship besides we have seen Lego leaks
where a Thanos is attacking the Avengers
headquarters and a lot of people do
believe that in those scenes the
destruction that we see in the
background could be the Avengers
headquarters and it's massive
destruction
almost everything is in ruins and Thanos
has shipped the sanctuary to is huge so
it crashing down onto the Avengers
headquarters could definitely be
something that would happen and cause
such mass destruction and we do see his
ship in the trailers does Thea knows
figure out what the Avengers are about
to do go back in time using the mind
stone and then
to earth and attack them this is
something that many people have
speculated about and just may happen in
Avengers in game so that does it for
this week's theories let's do a quick
recap theory number one is that Tony's
dream in Avengers infinity war it wasn't
actually a dream but it was his memories
catching up to him from a timeline that
he's already lived in theory number two
is that the Avengers will go back in
time and end up in the wrong timeline
they meant to go too and in that
timeline they see spider-man 2099 theory
number three is that Thor will go and
try to kill thanos by himself and
Captain Marvel will have to stop him and
this is the reason we don't see the two
of them in the scene where all of the
Avengers are wearing their white suits
theory number four is that when the
Avengers go back in time they'll have to
split up into two different groups and
theory number five was that famous ship
falls on the Avengers headquarters and
that is what causes the mass
destructions and the scenes that we see
in the Avengers and game trailers so
that's it for this week's theories don't
forget to vote on which one was your
favorite and if you would like to submit
a theory of your own you can find the
email to send it to and the instructions
in the description down below if you're
new to few Thursday's be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest episodes and of course so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers and Game in all
things Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you